Where is the energy stored?
In the previous example we have three charges 2+ and 1-,
and we want to know, well is the energy stored in the charges?
Somehow in the space between?
And the answer is that the energy stored in something called the electric field.
Now the concept of the field is a strange one. So don't worry if this is intuitive at first.
We actually could have talk about this concept of a field when we talk about gravity.
So for example, if you look at the earth, we can draw this imaginary
arrows pointed towards the center of the earth and these arrows somehow indicate
what would happen if I put a mass near them.
If I put a mass in this arrow, well it will a feel force into the direction that the arrow is pointing.
These arrows are somehow representing the gravitational field.
The electric filed is very similar in the same way that gravity is caused by mass,
electric fields are created by charges, and just as gravitational fields are felt by mass,
electric fields are felt by charges.
Both created and felt by objects with charge. Interesting!
Now, how are we going to measure the electric field.
Well it must have some strength associated with it.
The way we measure that strength is by putting a small test particle
with a charge let's say +q somewhere and if there's an electric field, this object will feel a force.
Electric fields cause forces, and of course if this charge were bigger, the force will be bigger.
But it seems like there's something more fundamental going on
than the force on this particular charge.
Actually, what we want to do is to find the electric field in the following way
as being equal to the force but we divide
by whatever the charge of the particle we're putting in this.
If we find that there is some force in this direction
that means it must also have been an electric field in this direction at this point.
As a quick example of how to use this equation, E=F/q.
Let's say we take our +1c charge, set it down somewhere
and note that it feels a force to the right of 4N.
Well the electric field is just force over charge 4/1 and both of those numbers are positive.
In this case the E field or electric field would be 4N/c
and maybe I'd want to say something like to the right because electric field is a vector.
It has both the size and the direction. Now what if I gave you a different problem.
Let's say I have a negative charge that when placed in a certain electric field
fills a force of 10 N to the right.
Can you fill this out for me? Can you tell me what's the strength of the electric field is?
And that strength should be a positive number
and can you tell me whether it's an electric field to the right or to the left.